Can you explain what nitric oxide is? My conventional doctor recommended me to take two capsules per day. Is this okay to take with the rest of my supplements?
No, so let's talk about that. So nitric oxide is a nutrient that is typically prescribed
by functional medicine doctors and naturopaths and things to it stimulates a certain receptor of the smooth muscles that light the arteries.
So there's the arteries are light by an epithelial cell single cell epithelial cell called anothelial cells and under that there's a layer of smooth muscles.
Now the smooth muscles are intermated, leading the neurological connection to the smooth muscles is the autonomic nervous system.
However, the autonomic nervous system separates into two components, the sympathetic and the parasympathetics. So if there's a sympathetic situation, leading a police car pulls up behind you and turns out in sirens.
You feel like your blood pressure goes up. Why? Because your sympathetic's kicking what your sympathetic's do is they contract cause those smooth muscles underneath the epithelial cells to contract. Why? Because there's a crisis situation and when those contract your vessels get smaller.
It makes the blood go through them faster because it needs to shut blood to the extremities so you can run away.
That's what a sympathetic response does does other things too, but that's what it does to the blood muscles. So it causes an increased blood pressure.
So if a person has an increased blood pressure and they're dealing that's what they're dealing with is a hyper blood pressure so they have a high blood pressure situation, nitric oxide would be a help for that.
So nitric oxide helps to.
It goes and attaches to the certain receptor on those smooth muscles called the end utensin to receptor and it causes that muscle to relax that's what nitric oxide does to the smooth muscles causes that smooth muscle to relax.
Nitric oxide also stimulates another pathway. So first of all, let me finish that discussion. So the number one reason why a person would choose nitric oxide as a supplement. The number one reason is to decrease blood pressure.
The number two reason is to is to is for erectile dysfunction. It can be very helpful for that because if you can open up the blood vessels, you're going to get an increased blood flow to an area, we need a better quality blood flow to the area, more oxygenation to the area.
The problem with nitric oxide and cancer is that nitric oxide also stimulates a whole other pathway called your veg F pathway, your vascular endothelial growth factor.
Well, that's really good to stimulate that Jeff if your problem is high blood pressure because you might have actually some damage to blood vessels if you've had high blood pressure for a long period of time.
Therefore, that Jeff would be very beneficial vascular endothelial growth factor would be beneficial in that case because we want to grow more blood vessels because that's what vascular endothelial growth factor does. It helps stimulate the growth of new capillaries.
So we want to stimulate the growth of new capillaries, especially around my heart. So if I have heart issues, blood pressure issues, then you taking nitric oxide is one of the best things for you. It's a great product.
If a person does not have cancer, but has blood pressure issues or let's say it doesn't have cancer, but doesn't even have blood pressure, but has heart issues in the family taking some nitric oxide can be very important.
We actually look at persons genetics and if they don't have cancer, we may recommend nitric oxide based upon their genetics because that's a whole other gene pathway genetic pathway is how you make nitric oxide and it clicks with vascular endothelial growth factor.
The problem, though, if a person has a diagnosis of cancer is that we do not want to stimulate vascular endothelial growth factor because that will help stimulate the growth of new capillaries into a cancer.
There is a boatload of research on trying to find drugs that will stop Vegef that will block Vegef in cancer patients.
So I would not recommend a cancer patient taking nitric oxide. Why because it stimulates Vegef and you don't want Vegef stimulated with cancer. So that's what you could go back to your doctor and say, yeah, I've been doing some research and I don't think I want to take Vegef because it stimulates Vegef vascular endothelial growth factor.
And that's not what you're supposed to stimulate when you have cancer and there is a boatload of research on that you could just Google it.